bonsoir
franchement j'ai fait lyon monsieur
lefebvre est ce que vous êtes étonné
qu'on soit rendue comme ça à plus de 6%
aux etats-unis et est ce qu'on peut
encore dire que c'est temporaire ou
transitoires
mais je pense qu'un petit peu des deux
je pense qu'on avait prévu que
l'inflation annuelle à les monter un
certain niveau à ce stade-ci un poste
repris sinon je dirais au post crise
plus tôt donc on savait que les effets
de base à les faire gonfler l'inflation
mais ce qui surprend c'est c'est la
vitalité mois après mois depuis je vous
dirai
donc probablement qu'on apparaît certes
un pic ils vont avoir un ralentissement
disons mathématiques au niveau de
l'inflation les effets de base vont
entrer en jeu et probablement qu'on
pourrait avoir un
retour à la normale au niveau de
l'inflation mais ce qui inquiète comme
ainsi qu'un bain probablement que d'ici
la fin de 2020 dont les effets de base
de son cours ce sens fort ont dissipé on
va voir si les effets de base au niveau
du choc de l'offre pour s'encourageant
d'entendre que monsieur par les nazis
parce que
les blacks ou simple à sioniste que l'on
vit présentement c'est à la fois un chef
doit faire un choc de demain le choc de
demande par un plus persistants parce
que ce qu'on voit c'est que les ménages
se sont enrichis durant cette crise nord
il ya beaucoup de munitions je vous
dirais qu'ils pourraient faire en sorte
le cas la demande va rester forte dans
les mois qui vont venir mais que ce soit
au niveau des semi conducteurs par
exemple qui tournait très important dans
la fabrication de voitures la production
va augmenter et ça devrait à terme le
mener peut-être un ralentissement qui a
déjà commencé il faut se le dire dans
certaines commodités de très importantes
au niveau mondial le président us byden
indiquant même que l'inflation fait mal
au portefeuille des américains ça fait
ça entraîne une érosion nécessairement
du pouvoir d'achat surtout si
l'inflation est plus forte que la hausse
des salaires c'est quoi l'impact réel
actuel et futur là qu'on peut en
attendre sur la croissance économique
un très court terme c'est sûr qu'il faut
il faut être capable de faire la
différence entre ce qui va rester encore
puisqu'ils ferment niveau de l'inflation
si jamais ça devait se maintenir encore
sur plusieurs longs mois ce après avoir
une incidence le en a pas et surtout sur
les ménages mais quand on regarde
l'enrichît un conte de vue au niveau des
ménages comme je le disais c'est certain
que beaucoup beaucoup de de munitions
encore qui font faire en sorte que la
croissance économique va demeurer
relativement forte à court et à moyen
terme dont c'est la première chose on
peut voir aussi l'inflation comme un
indicateur très précurseur au sens où
cette inflation l'homme en et devra être
corrigé par les banques centrales si on
devait augmenter les taux trop
rapidement à terme ça pourrait amener un
ralentissement économique et donc celle
du puceau qu'on est en train de mesurer
le haut niveau des anticipations des
marchés il pourrait avoir un choc ou une
mauvaise décision au niveau des
autorités monétaires dans la foi que on
laisse l'inflation galoper ou à la fois
on est trop rapide dans l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêt il s'amènera un
ralentissement trop
rapidement là on dit qu'on revient à
1990 et quand on regarde les années
soixante dix les années 80 on est à 15
20 % est ce que dans votre esprit
rassurez-nous on exclut la possibilité
de revenir dans cette eau là
mais pour le moment c'est pas dans les
scénarios dont parle de cette inflation
certaines personnes ont émis des
hypothèses face à sûr mais il faut
savoir qu'un bon l'inflation comme je le
dis aujourd'hui et à 6.2 peut-être qu'il
va augmenter encore sa vie si on
maintenait la sur une base annuelle
l'augmentation conduit dans le mois on
aurait une augmentation le qui avoisine
horaires ou tout au plus environ 7 5%
dans le courant 2022 donc même si on
maintient des fortes augmentations qu'on
nomme au / mot de fin certain temps
l'inflation sont ni repos à 15% pour moi
aussi que l'inflation si on exclut les
prix des commodités oui ça demeure quand
même relativement forme on n'est
vraiment pas dans ce qui a marqué les
années 80 et surtout les annales des
années 60 a fait 510 années 90 on en
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui donc c'est
2 on avait cinq points 4 au mois de
septembre 6,2 au mois d'octobre on
pourrait peut-être aller jusqu'à 7% là
aux états unis s conserva là aussi au
canada
madd canada on est un petit peu en
retard sur mon ange d'inflation va avoir
son cours des prochaines semaines
pour le mois d'octobre forcément tout et
tout indique que aussi on devrait avoir
un chiffre qui est quand même
relativement élevé mais c'est le même
phénomène vous savez au canada on est on
est bien nantie en ressources naturelles
le foie des de l'énergie entre autres la
il fait partie intégrante de notre du
calcul de l'inflation au canada mais
aussi l'ensemble des commodités et une
partie du shop on ne vit qu'au niveau
d'inflation c'est cette demande vraiment
très très forte pour les biens donc je
pense que dans le petit coup on se re
dirige un petit peu plus vers l'économie
de service au fur et à mesure où la
période de confinement tirait à sa fin
mais probablement qu'on va voir un
apaisement du côté des athéniens qui
préférent soit encore une fois que
l'inflation le on soit probablement dans
l'île dans les mois ou les fassions
annuelle est de me juger le vélo martin
lefebvre merci pour ces explications ce
soir
merci auront pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]